- We are back with
Shania Twain, everybody.
(audience cheering)
Her new album is called, "Queen of Me".
It drops tomorrow.
I wanna show the new
album, the single covers,
'cause y'all, I, at no point in my life,
will ever look like this. (laughs)
Like, what?
(audience cheering)
- [Shania] Yeah, yeah.
- I honestly wish we would've prepared
to have me on one of my horses.
And how, just the juxtaposition
of the difference.
I love this though,
because you are one of those
women, especially for me,
I just think growing up in the South,
you always had to be, you know,
turtleneck and skirt down here.
I think there's nothing
wrong with loving your body,
especially when you've been given that.
And then also, that's your own body,
that's your own sexuality, all of it.
I think it's beautiful,
and I think it's amazing
that you are comfortable,
and you loved it.
It looks like you, and it
looks like the word, free.
Whenever I saw it, I was
like, "Oh, she looks free."
- I think it's just very important
to be comfortable in our own skin.
I'm not an exhibitionist.
- I kind of am.
All right. (laughs)
- Do you walk around
the house with nothing?
- Totally.
- [Shania] Really?
- 100%.
- Good for you.
- I know.
It's not like with my kids hanging out
on the couch or anything, but yeah,
I don't have a problem with nudity.
- See, I always did.
I'm one of those people that never enjoyed
looking in the mirror with the lights on.
And now, you know, I'm 57.
I've been in menopause for years.
I'm like, okay, if I don't learn to love
what I'm looking at in the mirror now,
I'm gonna hate myself tomorrow.
If I don't look at myself today,
I'm gonna hate myself tomorrow,
because it's just getting
saggier or lumpier,
whatever it is getting.
- Gravity.
- Yeah, gravity's taking over.
- It's a wonderful thing.
- So I said, no, I'm
gonna start right now.
So I did that photo shoot,
I did a lot of nude photos.
I forced myself into, you
know, under the lights,
in front of the cameras
with the crew there.
Taking these pictures,
I'm marking this day
as this is the best I'm going
to look, anyway, forever.
So I might as well own that
and enjoy it while I've
got whatever that is at 57.